there we go
so yeah again so thank you to lornae and
our team and um also to the members um
of the committee especially michael our
independent member um certainly value
your input um we have three apologies
today um
councillor roman reid
doug grant and mayor tracy would someone
like to move it
uh stuart for lateness is going to zoom
in or
and stuart mcdonald
moved by richard seconded by john
always in favor please say aye
against motion carried
all right um
so we've got five items on the agenda
and then we move into public excluded so
let's move straight into
item number one um we have a health and
safety report from our general manager
people and capability nikki kuba welcome
nikki um quite a full report so i won't
actually try and
cover what you've got here but it'll be
quite good just to move through it i
think there's a lot of great information
here um so if you could just take us
through and perhaps highlight under each
heading
uh once you get your microphone going
no battery
you
hi good afternoon everybody
um so health and safety we have
increased the reporting um for the audit
and risk to reflect the changes that and
projects that the council have
undertaken in the last 18 months which
is why it's growing a little bit
um
based and we've also now structured the
report into sections
um upon some advice around
um the best way to present that
information i guess so building
capabilities just an overview of course
of all the staff training that we have
completed um since we last met and a lot
has gone on and that in that time most
of it is
compliance training
things that we need to have entire in
place um of note is the health and
safety rep training that has been
completed all five staff now have the
skills to be able to adequately sit on
that
team and know what it is that they meant
to be doing best to the best for the
council
in terms of our risk management so
site-wise obviously our contractor
program has it was new and we were
struggling to
implement and get it going we have had
some
continual problems i guess engaging with
some of our contractors but and after
doing a complete review of it we've got
55 percent as we can see who are
actually compliant which is a good move
forward so that's great um some that
need a little bit of help along the way
as you can see there and some who
we may just having a conversation and
engage and the fact that perhaps they
don't want to be council
contractors so we're going to have to
some honest conversations with those
people within the community
some that have contracted to us
but may just not see the need so also an
opportunity to speak with them about
do they want to be a contractor in the
long term for us and how can we help
them to get across from there
because we are with those um
once again contractor lynch so this was
initiative made by laurie um taken off
the back of belle cluther district
council which is just once again trying
to establish connections together
with our contractors so rather than it
always just be
them and us in this situation we had an
inaugural get together where we talked
about who we were and what our
intentions were and what our journey was
and how we could support them and we
hope this to be a series of events every
quarter um was well represented by the
managers and i think overall
yeah that was good it was many roads and
may it continue to just strengthen
really so we'll move forward with things
like guest speakers
um hopefully be able to address have
been have more of a conversation about
what's happening with our contractors
how we can support and our expectations
of them um as we go through incident
reports by department that's i think
that's fairly self-explanatory
we are working quite hard in incident
reporting in terms of raising the
quality
of what our staff are bringing to us
and
for evacuation so we just it was just a
bit of a background oop
yep
uh question through the chair just that
graph i just couldn't quite get the
handle my head around that one
okay
what what's the percentage up the side
as a percentage of
what and the um difference between the
and then the morty sports complex number
against administration and the total
where does it all fit in to be working a
percentage
so is that is that 10 incidents
number of incidents and then what what
proportion was each was each each
category so we had 14 password for an
administration
what's missing is
right across to the percentage of the
administration
so in administration we only had
problems
in two areas
and the
75 percent nearness
and 25
were planned
there's been high interpretation but
there was a heading and two
but but the percentages represent the
breakdown of the incidence
in terms of what category they sat in is
that correct yes near mrs plant injury
or contractor
thank you
no wonder that was confusing
correct
so the initial um
objective of contractor link is to
establish
a common ground and an open dialogue so
it's not a punishing
opportunity it is one of engagement
but it will be recorded who is there and
hopefully
we'll it will build momentum and more of
our contractors will attend
but if a contractor doesn't attend and
say the next two years
does that take them off the approved
contract with us no no so that's
separate so site wise
um does not have
a
criteria that has
contractor engagement in this form
so out of its nine five nine
your nine sections
yeah it doesn't this so this is
completely independent of uh site wise
and our physical contractor management
system it's an addition too
okay
thank you nikki
so moving on to
page three um i think really there's
unless there's
questions
around
this was general information
i guess the question i had was on
positive education
and director's knowledge was read on
page four yep and we're well below the
goal is that is that elected officials
uh referred to as directors
yes
there a plan
um that's coming yes so when your um
your new council rolls in i think the
last time we were ordered in risk i
highlighted this fact that we were
showing quite low in this governance
area um then you still need to be formal
training
yep
so what does that look like
in some some boards i've been on may
require
the directors to visit
sites
i believe elected officials aren't
subject to the same
criteria as as directors
but we certainly need to be informed so
i'd be quite interested i suppose we'll
hear about this in the future if we're
if we're re-elected as to what the
council's expectation of council
is in this area
so one of the projects for
2023 is to establish site walks gimba to
start them because the council doesn't
have them as such so that will certainly
be discussion of how involved but
from my point of view as people and
culture it would be my expectation that
a that a counsellor of some description
at some stage would show
their face to the company and and to the
council that course depends on
where
ce and
council decide
anyone's got a question yep no i i'd
agree because we went down the material
water plant we picked out a few things
that just weren't obvious and then i
thought
you know it's obvious things sometimes
are just sticking out to some people not
to others and for a counselor if he's
got a responsibility on top he should
probably have a site walk around quite a
few sites
rather than the entire council being on
a bus and seeing facilities i think
could be a place for delegation or
some form of
areas of responsibility portfolio set
but anyway that's not going to hit
ourselves but that may not be a concern
anyone else got any
points i'd like to raise i just like to
say nikki that's a fantastic report
certainly like the content and format um
okay and the fact is this there's a lot
happening i really like on page one when
you see the contractor engagement site
wise the word assist that's exactly
that's exactly what we'd like to see but
the contractors have to do their part as
well so fully accept that so with
someone like to move that the uh
the report be received john and seconded
by richard all those in favor please say
aye
against motion's carried
okay pace
oh sorry i've got to get used to looking
here
question or comment sure
i would quite um to see going forward
the actual dates of those trials
by the different sites
so that we can actually see that we are
complying because this report doesn't
tell us
yes
note taken we'll make sure that it's on
the next audit risk
thank you michael sorry i'm struggling
to actually remember to look to my right
you're sitting at my right on the screen
so you just have to sing out sorry yeah
he's oh is he
okay hey uh number item number two
quality treasure report that's on page
six we've got a memo here from launae um
and attaching the bancorp
treasury dashboard as at 30 june
um
just covering off our current situation
uh
cost of funds three point one five
percent at thirty june
and some debt drawn down since this
report was
was completed so lanai have you got any
comments you'd like to add
um
thank you mr chair and three year mr
chair uh the report is fairly standard
this is one we have on our quarterly
quarterly meetings so i won't add a lot
to it um you've highlighted the key
items um key items are that at year end
our balance was 35.5 million in debt um
since year a year and we borrowed
another three million um so we're
currently seeing at 38.5 million on a an
annual plan figure of 50 million so um
we're still 12 million shy of where we
had budgeted to be at the end of 2023
um the only other thing i was going to
point out which is explained in the
report is there is a slight breach at
30th june there was a breach of our
percentages and this is to do with
hedging policies and ad bans within
which we operate
this has subsequently been corrected for
by the liability management liability
management policy which was um accepted
and adopted in the july council meeting
so this is back in line with the things
that we're no longer in breach but other
than that i think you know the report's
fairly standard
yeah thanks lanai i just commenting on
the breach um the treasury management
panel has the authority to
to recommend
that a council the council goes outside
that that policy so that was considered
by the treasury management panel at the
time and a deliberate decision made to
to not address it based on the upcoming
new new policy so
um technical breach on paper but in
reality it was it was correctly dealt
with
any questions for an a or comments
michael have you got anything on the
banquet report you'd like to
particularly
it's a reasonably standard report
and it was discussed at the treasury
management
my comment would be if we
didn't have the policy we had in place
we could have made some better decisions
michael
the policy was the problem now we've got
the policy corrected the market's moved
so hopefully we're we're ready to move
uh in the future
okay
thank you john
just just looking forward how's it going
affect their budget with increased
interest rates and
how fast are we going to start getting
those increases
with renewals
through the chair we do have a number of
fixed rate
borrowings which will help us
um our treasury advisor does um
is signaling that interest rates are
starting to come back and we'll continue
to come back over the next 12 months
they won't return to where they were but
um you know we are we're trying to work
with our working capital as much as we
can to avoid borrowing ahead of head of
need uh so we again we're taking that
policy to minimize our risk and minimize
our exposure as best as we can in the
current environment
michael pretz could could you make some
comments around obviously discussions at
the treasury management panel meeting
around
a a move to uh floating interest rates
uh being more favorable at the moment
there is some risk being there but that
is that is certainly a
a opportunity for the council under the
policy to to be borrowing in the right
the right um
interest rate category
great explanation thanks michael
so
there's no further discussion richard
yeah
just questioned through the chair there
in regard to the breach under that
policy compliance what what does it
actually mean where we have that in our
report it doesn't actually mean anything
does it like it's not going to be
carried forward and future audit so
either compliant or we breach so when
we're red flagged we just
carry that through and it'll self-right
from the policy change
no it was a potential future breach
okay
as opposed to a decision that happened
by accident so it was a conscious
decision it was consistent with the
treasury management process so the
actual
phraseology
is
really the question was um whether it
would come back to us but it won't
because of technical and it's absolutely
self-righting yeah okay so we just focus
on that just so it's clear on page 12
you'll see the little graph on the left
hand side
the red lines are the guidelines of the
old
old treasury management policy
you'll see about june
died was it before june 26 it steps
outside that
so it's a it's a breach that would come
up in that period if we didn't do
something about it now
so we we could delay that and still be
correct even under the old policy we
just have to take action in the old days
we would be taking forward forward swaps
forward starting swaps which we all grew
a great dislike for just to
put a circle around that so
good question though so you're sickening
the motion richard from
okay i'll put that motion always in
favor please say hi
against motions carried
okay page 18 uh we have a
memo from the chief financial officer
that your old totally new title old
title uh on sensitive expenditure policy
and procedure so i'll just go straight
to leno and not try and jump in and let
you
carry the explanation um thank you mr
chair um
so this is just building on the meeting
we had in june in june we brought the
sensitive expenditure policy and the
guidelines to audit and risk um this is
base this is effectively the outcome of
of that meeting we've taken away the
recommendations and suggestions that
were raised during that meeting and
we've put them into place so this is
just bringing the policy back to you um
for your consideration
happy to take some questions on it
yep thanks
if you read the uh the changes we raised
at the last meeting and follow them
through the policy they're tracked and
incorrect so um i think the
recommendation is appropriate we don't
want to relitigate it what we've already
already discussed and this is a clang
just to move that so richard's moving
that season by john
any comments from you michael are you
happy
my question relates to whether
there would be merit in us maintaining a
register
of sensitive expenditure
i'm not sure
i agree with doing that
but i raise it
no there might potentially be some
privacy issues
if we maintain a register with
to understand
frequency
and quantity
of these types of things that's the one
question
and the other
general comment i make
is that
i quite like documents that are
consistently laid out
and there's some aspects of this
document that aren't consistently laid
out
so
when you do the final accept changes if
somebody could go through and just tidy
up the layout that would be good
thanks michael just on the point you
raised with
stephen are you going to take that one
i'm happy to take that one um i do
recall from a meeting in june that uh
annually we would provide a sensitive
expenditure list to order and rest we
would bring it once a year to there and
we discussed about it being in
categories um so it would be in
committee and we could discuss it you
know bring it once a year to to audit
and risk
thanks for that one if there's no
further comments we have a motion always
in favor please say i
guess notions carried
okay um page 32 item 4 annual report
sorry that item has actually been
withdrawn um
it's been carried over do you want to
make a brief comment on that lena just
to update the committee
yeah thank you mr chair um
so
the annual report is still in draft
format we the auditors are on site
currently and it would be remiss of us
to produce um or put out to public a set
of financials that i've got are still
moving we're working through a couple of
key issues with with the auditors around
some treatment of some items such as
matter ridge and otama the time water
supply transfer so we want to make sure
we get that right and not mislead people
with wrong figures before before they
we've had that settled the other thing
we are waiting on is final revaluations
on our infrastructure assets which we're
expecting by the end of this week so
until they were there i was not prepared
to put a draft set of financials in
front of um on risk i will happily do a
variable debrief of where we're at and
for the audit committee and committee
thanks honey i just think it's important
to note
you know what are the issues we've
identified matter rigid might get some
interest we're talking about accounting
treatment of a transaction as opposed to
any potential clangers
strike in the community
correct it's it's a it's a new type of
arrangement for the for the council so
it's a joint operation and we're just
making sure that we are recognizing our
portion of their joint operation
correctly um and so there it is purely
accounting treatment rather than
numbers being
numbers being an issue
john still still hoping to get that
through to november meeting yeah
yep and we probably would have some
management accounts if
for the first quarter
and in london spa time i guess
is that realistic
hopefully yeah
okay
all right well the items are drawn so
there's no further just there's no
discussion we'll move to um
item five on page 33 the procurement uh
policy review um again this is a memo
from from launae what what is your new
title tonight sorry
uh general manager corporate support
corporate support okay
yeah i was getting a bit confused
between the two minutes because your
title has changed obviously in the time
frame that this has been produced so um
you look over to you um this again is a
coming back from
the previous meeting um so
yep thank you mr chair um
in the june meeting we had um external
consultant andrew douglas talking to us
about our procurement policy and some
items we might like to look at and one
of them was a supplier panel
staff have reviewed the policy and have
suggested some changes we've tried to
simplify it in places
and
and make it a little more clear as to as
to how
how procurement should happen in the
organization so there are a few changes
in in the policy so happy to take some
questions and some discussion around
around that and may call on the chief
executive to assist us as a joint effort
thanks lanai look i actually have got a
couple of points
to to raise and and happy to be
corrected because
you know you read through and it could
be covered later but starting at 3.1
um
who it applies to mentors council
employees
and contractors staff and suppliers
however the consideration of people
connected within family
i know we can't bind them by policy but
there is needs to be a consideration of
someone's partner thinking of a
situation in environment southern where
a wife provided
some services to council so whether that
belongs there under conflict i'm not
sure yes number seven so just that so
under next thing i had on
five point
two point four should that also refer to
the panel on point eight sub subject to
section six
um
there's a panel
um
consideration on
point eight so i was wondering it should
be saved to section six and eight i
don't know it's pretty pretty
uh 5.2.4
it's talking about eligible suppliers
subject to section six section six deals
with
[Music]
something different i thought
buy local and then should also refer to
the panel perhaps
yep
yep
and then skipping to
6.1
b
refers to specialist services being
legal engineering and planning would
project management also be worth
including in that
it has been a it has been an item of
discussion
the the through steven that's uh was a
deliberate omission
on the basis of being conservative and
allowing the committee to either
um
shore that up uh project management was
always on the
the border of is it a commonplace
service that can just be tended out or
is it a specialist service that requires
separate acknowledgement in its policy i
wasn't sure of the mood of the committee
so i thought i'll play it conservatively
when we actually put this together
i personally would be comfortable seeing
it in
but
i think it's a
point of political discretion which
should be
the sole preserve of the committee
well from my point of view this isn't a
license to to um for that that
organization or whoever it may be to to
charge what they like it just it just
recognizes that that is a is a
specialist service maybe it belongs
under the panel um so
yeah so i as i went on i came to that
yeah
uh your conflict of interest i think
family spouses needs to be considered in
there
um and then yeah under uh eight
uh approved contracts and supply panels
i wrote down uh
project management
there
and legal there need to be a mood john
you agree
yeah where were you richard
michael are you happy with that yeah so
we'll just pick that up as a
project manager
and the approved contractor supplier
panel so
and legal does legal need to go in there
it was back there but
three
8.2 yeah the less than 8.2 sorry
yeah
steve
through you as chairman i'd argue that
legal should be a special service
because
it's not one where you can just say
we want um
large legal firms to put forward the
awares quite often you have specialist
needs and specialist areas of law
whether it's employment
resource management
constitutional public
and
you by doing that approach
you may be precluding some of those
specialist boutique law firms that could
provide the service you need in a
specific area good point yeah
john
who sounds like a lawyer
okay i'll finish so many
and
yes
under the specialist services
i'd sort of crossed out the last part of
it that says and not subject to the
bi-local preference section of this
policy
i would have said that
it's already subject to it because it
comes under the
uh heading
right and therefore we'd be better to
pick up
one of uh steve's comments which is
uh
should be purchased on the basis of
fit for purpose almost appropriate for
the circumstances
yeah i think you're right michael
because yeah that is that is a buy local
section the uh where it points out
exactly yeah
so to me we have to have a different
principle for the legal because
i suspect in many cases
because of
conflicts and
prophecy issues so steve under that
approved contract to supply panel
section
should that actually point out an
approved
contractor section which would include
those those group of services that are
specialized because i think what the
point michael's making is the buy local
refers to them
where where are they isolated as
that's where the talent is you're not
going to go tindering on legal services
when you we just need a job done now
yeah i'm just trying to
get my head around if you put specialist
services in
your contractor panel
the idea behind the panel is to
have groups of suppliers that can
do
that you know they've got trustworthy
work or goods and services in these
broad categories
what i said before was that something
like legal services it's specialized you
want to go straight to
the specialist service
and
you
may not be so much price sensitive but
the expertise that you require in a
particular issue
and therefore i don't see it being in
the panel section it's the exception to
the buy local
i guess the question i have is is that
section approved contract
supply panel does it uncover cover both
scenarios
no not not in my view
my view is this is just
where
staff want to be able to put in place a
panel of
trustworthy contractors or suppliers
under these particular broad headings
and then you know that
price wins a day
my example of legal services is that
you've got a particular
issue
you know just off top of my head it
might cover say
negligence or nuisance or and you've got
a health and safety is a classic one
and you've you've got an absolute need
to go to a specialist in this area
you're not price sensitive you're
expertise sensitive and therefore i
think it's
your
it's a natural default to buy local
but where does a policy provide
aside from buy local where does this
procurement policy provide for you to
just go to one firm with its engineering
legal
to just source that that task is the
policy
allowing that
well i thought it did i think that their
policy provides the the ability because
we define specialist services
and then
under the buy local
we say save for i just need to be the
right session right six point uh
legal advice
what yeah
we might we might just have to leave
that with you with the intent so when it
goes to full council you can just check
that out guy just it would be good if we
can just massage so
the just so i'm clear that
we're clear that we've got the
contractor supply panel and if there
needs to be further
uh services added and then as of like
today for example project management
services go into that section yeah and
then we have the
exceptions to buy a local
where
you've got a a need for
either an urgent need but also a
specialist need and the specialist need
is defined
i just
one of the perils of being online as
opposed to having a good hard copy in
front of you
um
but
if if i'm reading the meeting correctly
you want to preserve that ability to go
straight to a specialist
to get
a particular task or assignment done
and
that sits outside the approved
panel system of section 9.
yes yes
yep so michael's right that section nine
needs modified because section nine
allows
for procurement outside the panel
but then it restricts you on on value so
ten to twenty five thousand you have to
have two written quotations yes that
defeats the purpose of engaging the
legals so yeah similarly certainly
capture their attention yeah
on that same page sorry michael yeah
yeah
um
yep and the other thing i just
reflecting on page 44 8.11 versus
um 29.1 it seems
that with a panel in place you're more
restricted in terms of
procurement than you are outside the
panel so 10 000 or less you can get one
quote on
8 11 a
b and c it sets out those criteria it
seems more restrictive than
291 abc
am i reading that right so
um
you've got to get three written quotes
for items over 25 000 when it's in the
panel
the intent mr chairman was that the
thresholds would be
the same
if they're not that's an error because
there was
my intention was to tie them up but it
was also a point of discussion that if
the committee felt that
once you're in the panel system you
might want to relax those thresholds and
give greater ability to just
secure
one price
uh if
you're you're happy and under a higher
value but again this is a matter of
comfort levels politically
my view is is
once in the panel you should have more
confidence
so it should be more
less restrictive i shouldn't say but
yeah just to make the point so
under b that ranges from twenty five
thousand three to a hundred and fifty um
requires written quotes you're in at
twenty five thousand and there on um
under a11c
what would your view be in terms of
permissiveness under the panel to
to give the committee something to
consider i think
like is 10 000 or less
i i
i'm probably thinking mr chairman that
you could possibly combine
the first two categories into one
so that
if it's 25 up to 25 000 you could
approach a company with confidence
who've already gone through the
the
process of being
critiqued and ticked off as a reputable
supplier
and then using the i guess the judgment
of the
manager concern
don't have a feel up for 25 000 whether
that price is right
that's a possible outcome or or it's way
forward yeah
and two two quotations would
take you through 25 and greater two
quotations rather than three
john
just interesting like a three waters
pump that time i was scared to replace a
pump the other day was 26 000.
you know you need it now
yes you don't want to muck around yeah
so you're suggesting in our current the
numbers have reset in this world asset
values are
yeah
we need to actually be a bit more
realistic is it 50k really
it's a matter of mr chairman of just
your political comfort what you're
comfortable with i mean
i certainly don't want to give a feeling
of being blase but we need to be real as
to what these components cost and as
john's pointed out actually be able to
make place the order and get operational
again
[Music]
um a number
and i would say that 25 is too low
where
there only needs to be
one quote
and if the manager does a poor job
then sooner or later somebody's going to
have a performance discussion with that
manager
and so i'm going to be quite relaxed
about 25 becoming 40 or 50.
and above that 40 or 50 then there's
going to be at least two heights
and i'm not sure
having gone through and identified
people who are committed to the values
of the council and meet the quality
standards of the council we want to
very good point
so what's what's the mood on there i'm
pretty comfortable at 50. john's saying
40.
50 is ok
richard
yep yep certainly we'll certainly hear
back from council when this goes to full
council if it's yeah if we've
overstepped but
i think it's going to get real
and budgets budgets will dictate this
whole
a
table
that the panel can go up to so could we
have a 500 000 contract
or is that so large that we really need
to go out to the normal procurement
policy
council would be
steve johnson yeah through you mr
chairman i think if you're getting into
that sort of
area yeah you'd be you would be going uh
out to formal tinder because it would be
accompanied by
uh a detailed design
um
and
you're probably gonna get
a reasonable variation on price and
therefore it would behoove you to
to to go out into a formal tender i
would think
i just asked lauren to comment on that
figure 50 000 because you know you're
dealing with the
the invoices you'll know where they
where they're striking and where the
pressure points are yeah uh thank you mr
chair and through you mr chair the i
mean it depends on what part of the
business you're in i think um there's
certain areas where um 50k would seem
quite a lot and would be quite a big
part of their budget but for organized
parts of the organisation such as three
waters and roading and in the previous
meeting we provided a good example of
where we had a situation where to get
additional quotes um would have cost the
organization more so the pragmatic view
was to um seek for a
uh departure from the policy so it's
more to more to cater for those kind of
situations where where it doesn't make
sense to get an additional quote um but
for you know someone like finance um you
know we wouldn't necessarily need to get
the 50k
um
an administration yeah
yep so for me it depends on the type the
part of the organization
that it hurts but there's always a
common sense check with general managers
checking stuff off anyway
there would also be the chief executive
delegation that goes to those each and
every staff member around spending
limits so there's another check chicken
balance there
yeah
john were you going to make a comment or
sorry i jumped down with more navy
or something announcing
gone past it's okay
all right
so
any other michael you've got any
yeah good good good progress made wasn't
it yeah
richard and john are you okay
so would someone like to move that the
policy with those
amendments
and recognizing some of those will need
some
some discretion
of partners massaging sections right yes
since section 3 really relates to
people we control
which is employees
agree good point i did actually say
three or seven i think the chief you
might have heard my mumble uh
steve was looking at steven so good
point agreed
okay so emotion that the um
the policy with
the amendments and the appropriate
discretion applied to those go forward
to the full council
what is the recommendation
we are endorsing the
endorse the review
procurement policy
with the suggested changes an
appropriate discretion applied by the
chief executive
chairman just to highlight too that once
this policy is in place it's not as if
it's
set in stone if there are
some
unintended or unforeseen
uh
areas of uh difficulty in terms of
operating it effectively will bring it
back to order risk for a fine tuning if
need be great
thank you good job done there thank you
so
do we have a mover
john and richard
sorry all those in favor please say aye
against the emotions carried so that
brings us to the end of our open agenda
we have business to consider pursuant to
the local government officials